ALEKSEY SURKOV: I'll tell you
about Chrome Web Store today
from various perspectives.
So just to remind you
what Web Store is,
this is Chrome Web Store--
chrome.google.com/webstore.
How many of you have installed
at least one something
from Web Store?
Right.
And how many of you
have uploaded something
to Web Store as developers?
OK, good, so about 50%.
So the goal of my presentation
is to-- I actually
have two goals, I guess.
One goal is to give
you some idea why
you might be interested in using
Web Store as a new distribution
channel if you are not
doing this already.
And the second goal is to give
some tips, or some things which
are harder to find
in the documentation
and at which might make
your app more effective
and just bring you more users.
So Web Store is supported on
all our desktop platforms-- Mac,
Windows, Linux.
We don't support any
mobile browsers yet,
so don't try to open the
link from Android or iOS.
What kind of content do
we have in Web Store?
We really have three types
of items in Web Store.
We have applications.
And applications can
be hosted and packaged.
So hosted applications
in Web Store
are really just
links to websites.
So if you have a website,
then making a host application
in Web Store should take
not more than a few minutes.
But the benefits
that you will have
if you have this host
application in Web Store
is that you will be able to get
user reviews, user feedback.
For users, it will be
easier to find your website,
your web application.
They will be also able to read
some additional information,
like description, and
see some screenshots.
So I'll go in details
about that later.
Packaged apps are something
slightly different
from just hosted
apps, hosted websites.
Packaged apps is, in
some way, a website
which is packaged as a zip file.
And at the install
time, it's downloaded
to the user's machine so
that it can work offline
without internet.
So one of the biggest
advantages of packaged apps
is that they are
offline by default.
They just work without internet.
Another advantage is that they
have access to various APIs
which are not available
for just normal web apps.
For example, they can interact
directly with a USB port.
They can also use these
API [? pieces ?] [? just ?]
directly.
And they can do
many other things.
They also run in their
own separate window,
so on operating systems like
Linux or Mac or Windows,
they just feel like
native applications.
Extensions are things which
implement some functionality
in the browser, in Chrome, which
doesn't exist there otherwise.
They interact very
closely with the way
Chrome renders the web pages.
So one example of an
extension is-- obviously,
AdBlocker is a good
example, or an extension
which translates all the words
when you double click it,
and many other
things you can do.
And themes is just a way to
add colors to your browser
and maybe set some
background images to make
the whole browser experience
more personalized.
So we get, oftentimes, the
questions from developers.
They are wondering how
the homepage of Web Store
gets constructed
and what the way is
to get to the top
of this home wall--
the top of the home page.
I really just wanted
to give you a view
on how this wall
gets constructed
and what kind of
content is shown here.
So the first section and
the third section sections
manually curated by a
Google merchandising team.
So these are hand-picked apps.
Google uses different
signals to decide
which apps to promote here.
The signals include
things like the apps
should be high-quality apps.
It should also have
some popularity already.
So if you want Google to pick up
your app for a promotion here,
you really need to invest into
your own marketing a little bit
first.
It should probably use some
features of the platform
to showcase the
platform in a good way.
And it might be also a new
launch, an exclusive launch
on the Chrome platform.
We also have some
sections generated
using machine learning
and algorithms.
We have a personalized,
section which
is different for every user.
We try to select
stuff which is most
relevant to the particular user.
And we also have
just popular things.
And then we have
this infinite wall
at the bottom of
the homepage, which
is a mixture of various
streams that I mentioned about.
So publishing to
Web Store really
involves three simple steps.
If you want to
publish a hosted app
and you already have a
website, then essentially,
you don't need to
create your solution,
because you already have one.
You just to add a Chrome
manifest, upload to Web Store,
add some promotional
information, and you're done.
If you want to
make an extension,
or if you want to
make a packaged app,
you really need to use the
APIs that Chrome provides
specifically for extensions
and packaged apps
to use all the features.
And let me zoom in a little bit
on what promotional information
we require for publishing
and why it's important.
So you need to give us things
like promotional images
that we use to render
your apps in the wall.
And these images should
be of high quality,
because we don't really want
to show low-quality images
at the top of the wall.
So we have a manual curation
process for the images
that you upload from Web Store.
And if we think that image
is low-quality, or maybe just
a blank rectangle
without any information,
or a lot of small text--
there are some guidelines
for that-- we mark
this image as not
to be shown on the
top of the wall.
And then your item, even if it's
a very good, high-quality item,
it will not be able to show
up at the top of the wall.
So it's really important to
have high-quality promotional
images.
It also attracts users.
It's also important
to have, for details,
screenshots which show
how your app works
or how your extension works.
And the detailed description--
we know from user studies
that users really love
detailed descriptions.
They love detailed information.
They try to learn more before
deciding whether or not
they want to install.
They're really
cautious about this.
They also read
reviews and ratings,
so it's good to have
good reviews and ratings.
It's especially important if
you want to monetize your app,
if you want your users to pay.
So for monetization, Web
Store offers multiple ways
that you can monetize your app.
The most straightforward way--
at the same time, probably
the way to scare most users
from the very beginning--
is to have a prepaid app
or a prepaid extension
where the users need to
pay in order to install.
So if you have an extension
or a packaged app,
this will just work for you.
Web Store will not let the
user download without paying.
But if you have a hosted app,
which is essentially a website,
you also need to interact with
the Google Web Store server
to query whether the
particular user has paid
for the particular
application, and then you
can decide what kind of
UI you want to render.
Maybe you want to tell
the user to upgrade,
or maybe you can provide
some free functionality.
You can also enable
a free trial, which
means that your app will
be able to get installed
without paying, but then you
can implement some functionality
to check whether or not a
payment actually happened.
And there may be
limits on functionality
in the application.
We also recently
launched in-app payments
maybe a few months ago.
In-app payments give you a
way to configure what kind
of in-app products you want
to have in your extension
or in your application.
And then the code snippet
on the right side,
if you have an extension
or a packaged app,
that's really all you
need to do to query
what kind of in-app our
products a particular user who
is currently using your
product has purchased.
And then you can also act
accordingly, maybe-- open
some game level or enable
some functionality.
You're also free to use
your own custom solution.
We don't enforce
using specifically
Web Store solutions.
You can use anything you want.
And you can also,
obviously, use ads
just as you do it for websites.
So this is a feature which
was just launched yesterday.
Web Store format for
the manifest file
supports internationalization
and localization
to multiple languages.
So you can say, here
is my title in English
and my description in English.
Here my title and description
in Chinese and German
and every language
that you care about.
In case you don't really
know how to translate,
or you don't want to
deal with it yourself
how to translate your
description and your app title
to other languages,
is we now have
this semi-automated process--
and you can find it now
in your Chrome Web Store
Developer Dashboard--
where you can actually use
the professional translations
to request translations
for your listings.
The prices are-- for most
languages it's $0.10 per word,
and the turnaround time
is less than a week.
And we support 25 languages.
And the good news is that
for all of you who are here
listening to this talk, we
want to offer a refund up
to $100 for all translations
that you make from Web Store
by the end of this month.
So you can just go
to the link there.
It's also written
on the whiteboard.
And the first 50 responses
will get free refunds
for all translations
made from Web Store.
Another thing which
developers often ask us about
is why publishing an
app takes so much time,
why it takes so long.
And that's because we have an
app review process to fight
malware, abuse, and
other bad things.
Extensions, for example,
are very powerful,
and they can do a very bad
things to the user's browser.
They can steal all
the data, potentially,
and we definitely don't
want this to happen.
So we have a two-stage
review process.
When you click the
Publish button,
the app does not immediately
get available to all your users.
There is some delay.
And we use this delay
to first scan your item
using automatic
malware-fighting pipeline.
And the pipeline can say,
oh, the item is safe,
and then we publish it.
It can say, the
item is not safe.
It's malware.
And then we take it down.
And then it can also
say, I don't know,
but it looks suspicious.
So then, if it
looks suspicious, we
send it to manual
review process.
And it can take slightly
more time in that case,
so we have experts to look
at each particular item.
So what's important here is
that, even though it's sounds
a little bit scary,
most items get
published within 60 minutes.
And then it's very important
to monitor the email
that you use to publish
items in Web Store,
because Google
will use this email
to send your notifications
about any problems which
are happening with your items.
And in some cases,
it's very effective
to just appeal, or to
reply to the notification
some sensible way,
and then the item
can be restored
very quickly again.
Another feature I
wanted to tell you
about to in Web Store
is user feedback.
So everybody knows that
it's important to listen
to user feedback.
We offer a feature
which helps to simplify
interacting with your users.
You just need to opt in from
your Developer Dashboard.
And this two effects.
First, the users will start
to see a link to a Support
page in Web Store for your item.
And when they go there, they
can leave bug reports or feature
requests, or just ask questions.
And on the other hand,
you as a developer
will see a count of
unreplied feedback items,
and you'll be able
to reply to them
or just react to
them in some way.
Another interesting
channel which
was just launched
a couple of days
ago is called Google
Play for Education.
I want to tell you a
little bit more about this.
Google Play for
Education is a place
where Google Play team
and Chrome Web Store
team combined their efforts to
make this product for teachers
and their students
in the schools.
So currently, it has
Android apps and Chrome apps
which teachers can install
to their student's machines
and use that for
educational purposes.
So at this moment, we
just manually hand-picked
a handful of Chrome
Web store apps
and added them to Google
Play for Education.
But at some point in the
future, not too far away,
we will open this on the
opt-in basis for every Chrome
developer.
And you will be
able to just opt in
to Google Play for
Education program.
Your app will go through some
additional review process
to make sure that it's really
a good educational app.
And then you'll be able to get
this very powerful distribution
channel and sell
your apps or just
give it for free
to many schools.
You can go to this URL--
developers.google.com/edu--
and there is a sign-up form
where you can sign up to get
notified when this opt-in
opens for everybody.
So just to summarize the tips
that I've already mentioned,
any high-quality promotional
images is a good thing.
Having good screenshots and
detailed descriptions is also
valuable, helps users
to make their decision.
It's important to
monitor the email address
that you use to
publish your apps,
because Google will use it
in case something is wrong.
It's good to monitor
the user feedback,
and there are tools
for that in Web Store.
It's also good to localize
to multiple languages
if you target users in
other languages as well.
And invest into
your own marketing,
and then if you have a
good app, then chances
will be higher that Google
Merchandising team will
notice your app and make
it even more popular.
The last thing I
wanted to mention
is statistics which are
available to Web Store
developers.
So the built-in
statistics is something
that you just have for free
for every Web Store item.
currently, it includes
impressions and installs
that you get on a daily basis.
We are also going add very
soon sales statistics,
so if your app uses any of
Web Store's payment options,
you will see additional
charts and tables
summarizing how much
money you're making.
And the last option
that you can use
is you can just give us
your Google Analytics ID,
and Chrome Web Store will
ping your Google Analytics ID
every time when an
app is installed.
And you can then just
slice and dice this data
using all the power
of Google Analytics.
So I have a few links here.
I think the slides will be made
available after Google I/O,
so you'll be able to
just click through them.
One thing I wanted
to mention here
particularly is the
Cordova Project.
The Cordova Project allows
you to run Chrome Web
Store packaged apps also as
iOS apps and Android apps.
So it's a tool to convert Chrome
Web Store app to an APK file
and upload it to Android,
to Play Store, or to iOS app
and upload it to App Store.
And then there are some
other videos that you can use
or that you can just watch
about the Chrome Apps
platform and ecosystem.
And now I think I'm ready
to answer questions.
I have a mic here.
Just raise your
hand if you want to.
AUDIENCE: So I
have two questions.
At the beginning you mentioned
for the wall, that Chrome Web
Store wall, that we have to
invest our own in marketing,
but also if there's going to
be, say, an exclusive launch
or a new launch,
that the marketing
team or the merchandising
team will put that there.
So how do we tell the
merchandising team, hey,
we're doing an exclusive
launch on the Chrome Web Store.
Like, what's the
communication channel there?
ALEKSEY SURKOV: Right.
So how it works is-- one
communication channel you
can use is the discussion
group that we have.
We monitor it.
And if you really
have a good app,
and if you mention this
on the discussion channel,
then the merchandising
team will definitely
pay attention to this.
Then, for large partners, we
have direct communications
with them.
And when they launch something,
we to notice this fast
and also help them to
promote it in Web Store.
But our idea is that we're
going to build a merchandising
team pretty soon which is
going to be proactively looking
for new launches and
new popular apps.
So in the ideal
scenario, your app
will just get noticed by
the merchandising team
without your doing anything.
But I think it's
also good to use
Google Group to
tell about your app.
AUDIENCE: And
second question is,
for the impressions
and the analytics
that you showed, what is
defined as an impression?
Is it just the app
showed up in the wall?
Or is it when they clicked and
they got the more zoomed-in--
their [? modal ?] just looking
at the app or extension?
ALEKSEY SURKOV: So
impression is currently
the event when the user opens
the detail page of your item,
so when they clicked.
If it just shows up on the
wall, we don't really log it.
AUDIENCE: When you
use Cordova to publish
in Google Play or
App Store, can you
use the payment APIs
that you provide?
Will they work?
ALEKSEY SURKOV: That's
a good question.
I do not know the
answer to that.
But I know that they keep
adding new APIs all the time,
so the project is
very fast evolving.
And then just a year
ago, they had just
very small subset of Chrome Apps
APIs ported to Android and iOS,
and over the year,
they added a lot more.
So I think it's
either already there
or will be added at some points.
So you can go and check
out this Cordova website,
and they should
have the details.
AUDIENCE: I just wondered
because maybe Apple doesn't
want another payment API.
ALEKSEY SURKOV: Well, it
might be integrated with--
AUDIENCE: Oh, it could
layer on top of the Apple.
Oh.
ALEKSEY SURKOV: Yeah, it
might be on top of Apple.
I don't know the
detailed answer to that.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
To be featured on
the Chrome Store,
do we need to have a packaged
app, or can it be a hosted app?
ALEKSEY SURKOV: It can
be a hosted app as well.
We actually will try to promote
as well as packaged apps
and their extensions
and hosted apps.
We think they all are important,
like same-level citizens in Web
Store, and we will definitely
be promoting all of them
if they are of good quality.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
ALEKSEY SURKOV: Question.
AUDIENCE: How does the payment
API connect with the, say,
enterprise-- so, you know,
like in the managed domain,
you can specify, I want
everybody in my domain,
my organization, to have
this extension installed,
or to have this app installed.
How does that work
with the payment stuff?
Like, if it requires,
say, a one-time payment,
or it requires a
subscription, how
does the, say, administrator,
pay for all these users?
Because that's a
very flexible number.
Is it dependent on the number
of users in the organization?
Or does it wait until they
actually install the app?
I don't know.
It might be beyond the scope
of this discussion, but--
ALEKSEY SURKOV: Right.
So for enterprise,
I don't think we
have a good solution
in Web Store
for to just buy
something for enterprise
if it's a paid
extension or paid app.
So I have two answers here.
One is, there is definitely
a way for you in CPanel
to just preinstall something
for all the main users.
You can say, this
extension should
be installed to all the
main users for this app.
And then when they sign into
Chrome with their domain
account, it will be installed.
I don't think you can currently
use this for paid apps,
but there is definitely a
way to do this for free apps.
And the second answer
is, there is also
a project called Google
Application Marketplace.
And this is somewhat
separate from Web Store,
but this is actually focused
on enterprise use case.
And you can install
things there,
and they will get added
to this launch icon
with these colorful
squares at the top.
I can show you it.
So essentially, this
launch icon here,
it will have the applications
that you installed as a domain
administrator to all
your domain users.
So you can use Google
Application Marketplace
if you want paid
solutions, or you can just
install free extensions from
Web Store and the CPanel
in the special Chrome
Web Store section.
OK, so thanks for
your attention,
and I'll be around if
you have more questions.